in 2021 many people started searching
for KN car but there's no car company by
that name turns out people were
misreading Kia's new logo this change
was part of Kia's multi-million dollar
Rebrand in 2021 which included new
colors redesigned dealerships and a new
website this new logo is absolutely a
way for them to redefine their
competitive set they're no longer
competing with Honda or Toyota or Ford
or GM they're trying to compete with
Tesla so let's break down Kia's Rebrand
and see how it's using a new logo to try
to move its brand up Market
Kia has been around for almost 80 years
and in that time the company has gone
through six iterations of its logo the
history of Kia really is in
manufacturing and you see that with some
of the history of their logos Blake
Howard is the creative director of
Matchstick a brand identity firm in
Atlanta he's also the host of a podcast
that dissects logo changes and it wasn't
really until they went into the U.S car
market that they started to think more
about their own proprietary branded
vehicles or product this logo launched
in 1994 the same year Kia officially
entered the U.S market introducing Kia
where it differentiated itself with the
price of its cars and this reputation of
being a budget brand stuck along with
its logo Kia for years has been the
value brand in the U.S the sort of thing
that teens might get as their first car
here's what some consumers said they
thought about Kia the standard car value
for money products
but according to surveys by the research
from JD Power the quality of Kia cars
has been improving for years in the
early 2000s they started to focus more
on design car design the product design
and in a lot of ways the old logo felt
like it was an eyesore slapped onto that
more modern product that they had
already produced so now with this more
modern logo they actually finally feel
like the Kia that a lot of us maybe
already knew was out there Kia hopes to
chit's brand image with this 2021
Rebrand specifically with its new logo
so when we think about logo design there
are three things that we think about
shape color content and Kia made changes
to all three in terms of shape Kia
ditched the traditional container that
many other car companies use in their
logos so you can Honda has the container
Toyota has traditionally had that
container and that's because it's super
functional it's easy to slap on that
container shape as a separate piece of
artwork on any type of maker model of a
vehicle for color Kia swapped out red
for black to not only indicate a
dramatic change from its previous logos
but also to stand out from other car
brands the red and blue are the most
popular colors for Brands to choose in
the United States which is no surprise
and when you look in the car market you
see a lot of red specifically with
foreign import Brands Kia also changed
its brand colors to midnight black and
polar white it's no longer just a
generic red it's no longer a generic
white even the nuanced decision in color
like that signals that they're a little
bit more design driven consumers might
not generally recognize it at a high
level but I do think it all starts to
feel cohesive and it will build a visual
language for Kia over time that
hopefully is recognizable finally
there's the content of the logo which
involves the choice of typography it's
always idea deal to have the brand name
front and center out in the marketplace
as loud and proud as possible and Kia
chose to represent its brand name in an
abstract way but this design Choice has
caused some confusion saw this logo on a
car and thought it was Nine Inch Nails
the biggest criticism is around
legibility when people see a car brand
they expect to quickly understand what
the brand name is especially when there
are letters involved black space the
agency that designed Kia's new logo says
the lettering is meant to look like a
cursive signature they were inspired by
calligraphy and they were they were
working with different Korean glyphs and
the letters are built off of a
consistent parallel angled lines that
represent this idea of rising they said
the rising Strokes are meant to
symbolize the meaning of Kia which is to
come up out of Asia
another big part of Kia's rebranding
effort is redesigning its dealerships in
the U.S the new dealerships are really
designed to be less like an office space
and more like a high-end retail outlet
where the cars are laid out is sort of
open and spacious and metallic Kia says
it is also trying to attract electric
vehicle buyers who typically don't like
going to traditional car dealerships Kia
isn't the only car company investing in
a new dealership look nor is it unique
in changing its logo but what Mesa Kia
apart is the speed and breadth of its
rebranding efforts this is something
that usually happens
slowly and surely over a number of years
and Kia seemed to be by comparison doing
this at Breakneck speed
clearly Kia is on a roll they had their
best ever third quarter recently in
terms of sales in the U.S he has Revenue
shot up in 2021 and this year it
launched the ev6 the company's first
dedicated EV model and the Nero EV both
with a starting U.S sticker price of
around forty thousand dollars
Kia says it plans to release 14 EV
models globally by 2027 and it plans to
sell 1.2 million electric vehicles a
year by 2030. and that puts them well in
the running for among the top EV sellers
in the world but the inflation reduction
act which passed in August could throw a
wrench in Kia's ambitious plans the new
law requires cars to be assembled in the
U.S in order to qualify for the
government's 7 500 EB tax credit Kia and
its sister company Hyundai motor have
factories in the U.S for their gas
powered cars but their EVS are currently
made in Korea Hyundai's 5.5 billion
dollar EV and Battery Factory in Georgia
is only set to open in 2025. South Korea
and the US are currently in talks about
possibly figuring out a way around this
problem but if things don't change Kia
could face a huge challenge in reaching
its sales Target for 2030.
the other big challenge facing Kia is
that almost every major car maker is
coming out with EVS at the same time
every time that happens whether it's a
pickup truck a minivan a hatchback or a
new battery-powered vehicle the
challenge for these companies is always
how to stand out in those crowded spaces
with all the changes it's made over the
last two years Kia is not only betting
big on the EV boom but it's also banking
on the lasting Ripple effects of its
rebranding efforts branding really is a
long-term investment it's redefining
these micro touch points that will add
up to this macro feeling in the
marketplace over time what's modern now
might not feel modern in five or ten
more years from now but the Kia logo is
built off simple design principles so
that will endure
[Laughter]
[Music]